- We're taking this red
carpet very seriously.
- That's why we're asking everyone to--
We're at the world premiere of
Star Wars: The Force Awakens
in Hollywood, and we're
getting celebrities
to do their best Star Wars impressions.
(imitates Chewbacca)
That was Chewbacca.
(bouncy big-band music)
So let's start off with something easy.
Can you do a Chewbacca impression?
(groans like Chewbacca)
- Bad. Bad.
- I need a really loud one.
- No, you're only trying to embarrass me
in front of Max von Sydow!
(groans like Chewbacca)
(hoots like Chewbacca)
- We're asking everyone do
to their best impressions
of other characters.
So can we get a Chewbacca roar from--
- No Chewbacca roar?
(warbles like Chewbacca)
- (groans) Wait. (groans) Eh.
- That's embarrassing.
- OK, Mark said--
(groans)
- That was great!
- That was it.
- Can we get a little bit louder?
(groans)
- A plus, thanks Carrie!
- I'll do it with you. If we
do it together, will you do it?
(moans)
- Harrison told me mine was
awful, can you do better--
(moans)
- Thank you! Yes!
- Luke liked it, Han Solo hated
it, you guys have to decide.
- Do you think you can
do an R2D2 beep for us?
- OK cool.
(beeps and trills)
(beeps)
- Beep beep beep.
- Boop, boop boop boop, boop.
- How about an R2D2 beep?
- Beep.
- Pretty solid.
- Sure.
- All right.
- Boo dip dip. Bip bip.
I don't know, and now I'm
getting confused with BB-8.
What does R2 sound like?
Beep beep boop boop, beep.
- Yeah, you probably just like cursed
in R2D2 or something.
How about a light saber noise?
(buzzes)
(whooshes and buzzes)
- I don't know (whooshes).
- Pretty solid, I think you nailed it.
(buzzes and whooshes)
(buzzes)
(hums)
(whooshes)
- Thank you.
- Nice talking to you.
- Mew mew mew!
- All right, that--
Oh no, that's the planes!
- That's like more the ship.
- Oh I love those ones, because
I always go nerd nerd nerd!
- Mr. Stormtrooper!
Yes.
A word, could I have a word?